it's ramadan the holiest month in the
islamic calendar muslims around the
world are fasting from sunrise to sunset
in previous years it's been the busiest
time for markets in libya but shop owner
mohammed bhumenjir says prices for basic
goods have doubled and that means
business is not great
the purchasing power for people this
ramadan is much less than before prices
are rising every day and that's had an
impact on our business
last year the average customer was
spending around seven dollars for their
daily needs this ramadan is 13 to 15
many can't afford that
ramadan is also a chance for family
members to spend time together and share
a meal to break their fast but rising
prices have made it difficult for many
to meet their basic needs
i ask that god helps us all during this
blessed month of ramadan the situation
is dire for many people due to the
economic circumstance our country faces
those with four or five kids are really
struggling to feed their families
libya imports at least
650 000 tons of russian and ukrainian
wheat for about half
of what the country needs at the moment
there isn't a shortage here in libya but
prices for bread have increased
if russia's war in ukraine continues
countries in this region including egypt
and tunisia may soon run out of bread
if authorities here don't act soon libya
could face the same problem
akram
is head of the economic committee for
the city of tripoli he says the
government has a six-month strategic
wheat reserve and is working to increase
domestic production
uh municipalities
prices for goods are soaring globally
due to the russian ukrainian war
especially the price of wheat before
basic goods like wheat oil rice and
tomato paste were subsidised by the
government but that stopped due to the
political crisis and conflict
according to the un more than 800 000
people are in need of humanitarian
assistance in libya the average income
is less than 200 a month if prices
increase further many more may find
themselves struggling to cope
alec trainer al jazeera tripoli